Disney Princesses and main characters
are iconic but you know who's even
better their sidekicks over the years
Disney sidekicks have brought tons of
entertainment and while many side
characters got their own movies Disney
Princess sidekicks are still waiting in
line we just wanted to give Disney a
little hint you know just in case they
ever consider making a Disney sidekick
movie she's not a prisoner she's our
guest we must make her feel welcome here
Lumiere and Cogsworth from Beauty and
the Beast seriously these two are just
amazing they managed to entertain us
during the live action just as much as
they did in the original came off this
time Lumiere used to be the castle
servant and one of the few that speaks
with a French accent his animated
personality stands out from the crowd
and he's pretty much adored by everyone
even as a household object he remained a
beloved character
Cogsworth is much more serious which
makes him less appreciated in the castle
but when cogs and Lumiere are together
they really show us the meaning of
friendship they're complete opposites
that just work so well together but did
you know that their friendship has a
deeper meaning it's why we think these
two deserve their own story the
animators who brought the characters to
life actually have an adorable
friendship of their own Nico Donnie Airy
and will Finn are the animators behind
Lumiere and Cogsworth Nick is the taller
one and will has a round face similar to
Cogsworth according to behind-the-scenes
stories they share a similar humor and a
whole lot of workplace stories honestly
we'd happily watch the banter between
Lumiere and Cogsworth for a full hour
just imagine if the story of the two
animators was somehow incorporated in
their own movie their friendship seemed
so pure it really does deserve a bigger
future plus they're one of our favorite
Disney otps
as friends of course
Gong's laughs we beat the clock Mushu
and ricky crickets from Mulan Mu Shu is
by far one of the most beloved sidekicks
ever how could you not love him he was
once a guardian spirit
but has since then been demoted he's
pretty comical but often impulsive which
gives us some of the best scenes ever
because of his demoted status his ego
has suffered a lot which makes him quite
selfish but he loyally follows Mulan
which proves his heart is still in the
right place crickey on the other hand is
a lucky cricket given to Mulan by
grandmother father
so it's clear that the two psychics are
just meant to work together
crickey also chooses to follow Mulan
just like wushu and they even work
together to help defeat Shen Yue
although crickey is less expressive than
moo shu is due to the fact that he's
well a cricket but that doesn't mean his
interactions with moo shu aren't
appreciated there are plenty of moments
where crickey easily steals the show
we'd love to see even more scenes
between these two and hopefully we will
in the live-action as of January 2019
not much has been revealed about the
Mulan live-action but we can't wait to
see these two back in the game Pascal
from tingled speaking of favorite
characters Rapunzel's Pascal brought us
so many funny moments we feel like he
needs a second chance he was kind of
forgotten at times even though he did
help Rapunzel and Flynn on their journey
not to mention he was absolutely
hilarious
we know that Pascal lost his mom in a
snake fight which led him to discover
Rapunzel's tower as a character from a
popular movie Pascal was featured in
several other projects including tangled
the series and tangled ever after but we
generally love to see him have his very
own full featured story and it wouldn't
hurt if Maximus the horse was involved
in that too these two just make a
perfect pair and honestly we'd love to
see more of their crazy antics since
Pascal doesn't speak it might be harder
to develop a storyline that focuses on
him with Pascal's comedic timing we're
sure Disney can pull this one off
just imagine Pascal being paired with
other Disney characters comedy is gay
especially since we know that he stayed
true to his character even after
Rapunzel enjoyed her happily ever after
seriously we have strong feelings about
Pascal getting his very own movie no fan
I didn't get your carrots but I did find
us a place to sleep
spend from frozen have you ever noticed
how spend the reindeer is pretty much a
dog he definitely has way more
personality than any reindeer we have
ever seen
honestly reindeers really are better
than people he's absolutely comical
enough to have his own story featured
more and we honestly hope frozen 2 will
help with that
Sven can often be seen being playful but
he's also Stern whenever Kristoff is on
one of his antics can't blame Sven
really it's probably hard dealing with
Kristoff all the time
we'd go nuts in our ideal world spend
would be in a sidekick movie along with
Pascal and Maximus from tangled we feel
like these three would be the perfect
trio span would definitely be the
clumsiest of the two we know that he's
also easily distracted by things which
makes him even more funny honestly he's
so innocent and playful it's absolutely
perfect
combine it with Olaf the snowman and you
have yourself a perfect psychic story
seriously these two are just meant to be
we can already see this sidekick movie
being a huge success but wait until you
see what we have in store for you as our
number one psychic character it's one of
those that really is severely underrated
but more about that later let's carry on
with the video a boo from Aladdin ever
heard of monkeys being kleptomaniacs
a boo basically represents all monkeys
that have to face that fate a boo can't
resist a good steal and can be seen
quite selfish in that regard but being
with Aladdin makes you a better person
or better yet a better monkey and
honestly that's all that matters doesn't
it
a boo has had quite a redemption story
throughout Aladdin but we'd love to see
more of him he's been featured in quite
a few video games and was even shown in
the return of Jafar but having an
individual story with just a boo would
be absolutely glorious just imagine if
Disney makes the record Ralph - version
of Disney sidekicks put them all in one
room and give us one hour of footage we
bet a boo would bring out some of the
best comedy ever let's be honest
Aladdin wouldn't be the same without a
boo and this psychic remained loyal
despite being an obviously cheeky monkey
that alone shows his character has grown
a lot in just one movie we really just
wish Disney would honor him with his own
movie flounder from The Little Mermaid
it's about time we get another look at
the Little Mermaid isn't it
but before live-action is considered we
seriously think flounder would be a
candidate for an independent psychic
movie especially since he's not really
an actual flounder fish despite his name
flounder is loyal and protective which
makes him a perfect character although
he's quite scared of Ariel's free spirit
he really does stand by her side at all
times it takes a lot of courage to face
your fears just to remain loyal to your
friend we don't want another Finding
Nemo or anything like that but we're
sure Disney can come up with a story for
flounder after all he wasn't the focus
of the story after Ariel went with Erik
we want to know what's been happening
with him after Ariel's happily ever
after he has a larger role in the Little
Mermaid Ariel's beginning but we're sure
there's more scenarios Disney can put
flounder in especially if they pair him
up with other Disney sidekicks flounder
definitely deserves a chance at showing
more of his story just seeing what he
does all day would make us happy but
then again we'd also be happy seeing
flounder having a cameo in another
Finding Nemo movie
he honestly has so much potential we'd
hate to see it go to waste
come on Disney where you at you're an
outcast that's great so are we what you
do kid Timon and Pumbaa from The Lion
King this one is totally a given but the
one we actually really want the most
it's been a while since we've seen Timon
and Pumbaa anywhere but Hakuna Matata
remains the most iconic Disney song ever
these two buddies have definitely taken
care of the comedic timing of the
otherwise serious Lion King movie we
know they're coming back for the live
action which is fantastic news but come
on it's really about time they get a
well deserved movie of their own we
could enjoy jokes and vanta for days but
who actually did have their own show
back in the day and maybe it's time
Disney brings it back it was called
Timon and Pumbaa and it actually ran for
three seasons which is pretty impressive
we'll have to wait until the live action
to see whether these two still have what
it takes to make us laugh but we're sure
we won't be disappointed and just for
old time's sakes let's bring it back to
one of the most iconic moments in Disney
songs yep it's this one also sorry for
getting the song stuck in your head we
just had to dug from up here's one
character that's not strictly Disney
Princess related but that doesn't make
him any less important than the others
dog has had several cameos and other
movies but you probably know him best
from up
he's the happy-go-lucky dog who's kind
to everyone he meets he's good at
following rules and is known to be
easily distracted he kind of reminds us
of Sven from frozen
Doug belongs to Charles Muntz and the
several scenes he's had and up really
made us see the potential of his
character honestly Disney can we make
Doug the movie happen we all know the
secret life of pets became hugely
successful so how about something like
the secret life of Doug he already has
his own movie in Doug special mission
where he was his own narrator but that
movie was still a short one and it was
meant to show how Doug got to Russell
and Carl
[Music]
and that was happiest day of my life
we'd love to see what Doug is up to now
to spice it up he did definitely have a
storyline where he tries to protect his
owner from the bad guys you know
basically being a Superdog crick in the
neck
genie from Aladdin ah where do we even
begin with a genie from Aladdin
Jamie movies have always been a hoot
honestly we still haven't forgotten
about Shaquille O'Neal's Kazaam this
Sony could this world really really
gives me to you that I'm gonna do
something I don't ordinarily do
seriously if you've never seen that
movie do yourself a favor and watch it
this proves that Genie movies do have
the potential the genie from Aladdin has
been praised many times for his positive
bursts of energy honestly he's
irreplaceable he's so easygoing and
friendly you could put it in basically
any movie
we know that the Aladdin live-action
movie is coming and we hope genie gets
the redemption he deserves to have
that's a good move
I can't believe it I'm losing to a rug
just imagine a psychic movie with genie
and a boo honestly it would have been
the best thing ever
genie has a pretty sweet job just
imagine being able to grants people
wishes you're gonna grant me any three
wishes I want right all they have to do
is stick to the three wish rule and
that's it but of course genies biggest
wish is to be actually freed from his
lamp genie I wish for your freedom one
bona fide prince pedigree coming up we
really just want to see a story of Genie
being free once and for all come on
Disney ray from Princess and the Frog
and last but not least it's ray hear us
out on this one wait I know this story
if you're a fan of our Disney videos you
know we have strong feelings about
princess in the frog it's easily one of
the most underrated Disney movies ever
unlike other sidekicks ray
the Firefly is one of the few that
didn't really have any other appearance
apart from the main movie about time I
introduce myself my name Ramon but if I
call me a ring
come on who wouldn't want a Disney movie
about fireflies ray actually has an
adorable story and princess in the frog
he actually fell in love with a star how
she glowed right up there
this was envisioned back in the early
stages of Princess and the Frog so it's
nice to see that they capped the idea
ray might be small but he's incredibly
friendly and helpful at all times just
like other sidekicks he helps the main
character of the movie and is very loyal
he's also a super eccentric and easily
excitable as well as angry when he needs
to be on top of that he's very
intelligent and basically acts like a
father figure and a point of wisdom
basically he has a whole spectrum of
emotion which shows the potential of his
character she just began under broken
heart that is but because of the
underrated nature of princess in the
frog ray never got the attention he
deserves there are plenty of fireflies
in swamp
keep shining bright Remo your time will
come where can we put out a petition to
make this happen what do you think who's
the most underrated Disney sidekick of
all time
come let us know in the comments would
you rather see them in their own
individual movies or a single movie with
every Disney character ever and that did
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to the things for more feel-good content
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]